das klingt ja schon fast siegessicher
muss er jetzt auch mal demonstrieren
gleichzeitig aber jetzt gerade paul eine
rede erlebt die ich viele fragezeichen
hinterlassen hat warum er sich jetzt
nicht noch einmal dann streckt sich noch
einmal emotionen zeigt dass gesagt eine
lasche kann dass er kann eigentlich auch
emotionen jetzt auf diesen letzten
metern es war der letzte große auftritt
ich verstehe ich nicht warum aber ich
verstehe wirklich nicht warum er den
bogen nicht so gespannt hat wie er ihn
bei seiner rede um den parteivorsitz
gesponnen hat das wäre ja ein thema
gewesen womit man deutschland anspricht
der vater bergmann seine
familiengeschichte was daraus entstanden
ist wie er deutschland verändern will
was modernisierung bedeutet da haben
menschen angst vor das alles hätte er
anpacken können stattdessen den einzigen
punkt den ich gut fand war wo er ein
bisschen über innere sicherheit
gesprochen hat herbert reul erwähnt hat
den innenminister und das was er dort
getan hat ansonsten ein rundumschlag von
dem nichts hängen bleibt ein teil
einspruch nach einspruch
bergmann wäre ich weg gewesen beim
bergmann werde ich einfach weg ist als
wenn er den berg man jetzt noch mal
gemacht hätte weil der vater war
natürlich in den ersten jahren bergmann
der nach waren nicht mehr bergmann und
das wäre mir zu viel gewesen dass es da
kommt bei mir immer glück auf der
steiger hoch und damit kommt noch viel
mehr hoch prämierten habe als das in
deutschland thema also ich habe schon
dass es massen ansprechen mehr als der
nizza-vertrag absolut und er hat bei mir
einen anderen moment gehabt also eher
den rollen dokument und da muss man
wirklich sagen also über innere
sicherheit hat sprach das ist ihnen
quasi noch eingefallen sagt an den
lassen sie mich noch ein satz dazu
innere sicherheit um gesagt und dann hat
er das das gemetzel